un manoir pas comme les autres dans ce
village de sainte mesme dans le sud des
yvelines se cache l'une des plus grandes
collections privées de costumes
militaires de france
un trésor historique ouvert au public
depuis quatre ans ici les tenues et
armes installés sur des mannequins
grandeur nature date de 1870 à nos jours
la plupart ont une histoire en effet
parce qu'en fait la plupart des jeunes
femmes qu'on est si ce sont des dons
d'anciens militants siens dans sa
militaire dans cette feuille de familles
de militaires qui a donc lancé les
costumes ne servirait ne servait plus
donc au lieu de les jeter ou de prendre
trop la poussière le propriétaire les a
récupérés les a mis en valeur dans ses
collections en touring dans cet endroit
donc un endroit qui fait 15 mètres de
long et 1 à peu près de 97 en plus des
costumes d'époque les propriétaires ont
également créé un musée archéologique
sur la période gallo romaine
après avoir découvert plus de 3000
pièces datant de cette période dans les
sols du manoir le site était un ancien
espace religieux
c'est ici qu'on aura regroupé les plus
belles pièces de la fouille donc qu'elle
a duré de 1985 à 1989
concernant donc infantile gallo-romain
un sanctuaire gallo romains dédié à une
dsi s'appelait silvina qu'elle existait
langue du deuxième au troisième siècle
après jésus-christ et singuila en fait
c'était donc une baisse liée à l'eau et
son pouvoir particulier c'était que
grâce à louhans en fait elle permet tait
de guérir a notamment les maux de tête
et nous de ventre le manoir est ouvert
jusqu'au 20 septembre du vendredi au
dimanche la visite guidée de deux heures
est au tarif de 8 euros 50